thank you
[Music]
that's pretty so Anthony you're in South
Africa
go ahead Ryan go ahead tell us about
your trip to Africa
um so uh
I'll just I'm waiting for him yeah tell
us about it man yeah tell us this is
cool beautiful my friend was born in
South Africa and um would that make him
African-American because he's Chinese
I didn't know I was going to be this
confused at the beginning
I mean he should be right wait he was
born in Africa yeah he's born in Africa
but he's Chinese he's Chinese and then
he came to the U.S got a citizenship
here so does that make him
African-American
yes
but he's Chinese yeah I'll give him that
actively Chinese yeah he go hang out on
Crenshaw yeah tell them that he's like
hey hey look at me guys what are you
[Laughter]
everything did you know the the highest
um uh population of mixed marriages in
the last couple of years is Chinese and
black
I'm telling you in Africa well because
population there's so much dangerous you
know I will say Malaysian Blasian
beauties that did [ __ ] me up because
um so um just to catch all of our
amazing viewers up uh I recently just
went to South Africa we were Ken just
was invited to perform at the Red Bull
dancer style World Finals so it's just
like this giant uh type of uh battle
type of competition where every yeah
every country has a dancer style
champion and then the Champions come
together for the world final yeah it's
huge huge events it's not break dancing
no breakdowns is BC One so Rel bc1 is
for the for the B boys B girls and then
dance your Styles basically for almost
every other Street Dance written Styles
they all got it okay does this happen
too yes it does okay yeah and the
concept of it too yeah that's pretty
good
it takes you over the concept and the
the theme or the underlying themes of it
too are to make it way more relatable so
the DJs are playing like you know
relatable pop songs or top 40 things and
then it's
um fan voting so everybody's given a
electronic bracelet and then it's either
blue or red so when you watch the battle
at the end of it the host tells you like
who you vote for you put up your
bracelet or your hand and it shows light
you triggered which light you want so
which means that like dancers
perspective sometimes you might choose
something else but if the audience
happens to Just Vibe with somebody then
they're just choosing that winner which
uh it's cool concept it's different
right do dancers get mad like you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're voting on you
stupid ass you don't even understand
dance yes but they're like but that guy
did a backflip and you didn't so you
don't [ __ ] know how to do [ __ ] yeah
that's right a bunch of jokes in the
audience is dangerous for the dancers
but yes it does happen but it's also the
part of the concept which makes it dope
you know what I mean um there's like a
thousand jams in the world you want to
have certain things that are just
different you don't want to participate
in the same competition
um but we got invited out uh and we
performed there and and it did trip me
out because the second we landed
there were [ __ ] Chinese people
everywhere I shoot you not and we went
to jail I like Johannesburg China China
like as in like Chinese families were
speaking Chinese and welcoming Chinese
people coming off of the plane like
welcome to Africa yeah more like welcome
back welcome back hey welcome back to
Africa
do China in Africa like what are you
think is it like it feels like a Chinese
tourist group is letting like guiding
all these new tourists do they live
there
Johannesburg in Johannesburg
um and you know I this is my first time
in Africa in general and so my ignorant
ass was literally like uh I was asking
the person who was kind of picking us up
for the bus and stuff and I was like
um what's the main language spoken here
Chinese
that's funny they go you speaking it
brother
you don't know
doesn't that mean blm's doing a bad job
because they're getting taken over from
the inside out man oh [ __ ]
over here [ __ ] parading with picket
signs you're gonna take it over by
Chinese [ __ ]
what do you say Anthony all right
guys
I'm just asking questions well the point
is the main language spoken there's
English
um and second you didn't know that
second Point don't be yelling at me I
know right
one of us man
what's the other one that they speak
they speak like 11 other languages even
just in Johannesburg from like Zulu all
the way to [ __ ] I can't pronounce and
I'm not gonna even try it
you have 11 tries
wow that's good but yeah it's I think
they're the fun they're dangerous boy
probably like um Zulu probably Swahili
oh yeah go ahead you go ahead
carry on brother
carry on
Big D antwerth that's the only thing we
know from South Africa yeah like you
were saying it's like especially
jealousy it's super freaking westernized
like we we didn't even we were there
only four days we had a shitload of work
to do so we didn't go on [ __ ] like
safaris or anything yeah we stayed in
like the compound that they had us at
which basically looked like Little Italy
or some [ __ ] there was a casino
Italian restaurants everywhere and there
was a bunch of like really stayed at the
Venetian in South Africa and he goes man
it sounds like this Little Italy
chocolate I know right yeah
but for real it was just so uh
modernized and westernized in that way
and they did what if he was just in
Vegas
wow this is crazy
this looks like McCarran right yeah
Africa
there's a lot of Chinese people here
it's Macau it's not even [ __ ] Vegas
what do you expect we in Africa that's
crazy there's a lot of Chinese people
there there's a lot of lives I wasn't
expecting that trip yeah holy [ __ ] was
not expecting it myself like Bart said
blm's doing a bad job
but I do understand now when people have
said before and obviously again just not
even because I've never been there
African Americans and Africans are very
different people they're very different
they're totally different upbringing
they're totally different like
perspectives on stuff and and the vibe
is just different listen Africans go
hard
on black people
hard
do tell do tell oh man like
uh I've worked with quite a few African
dudes you know before like like straight
up like from Africa and they go hard on
like black people like they're like I
don't I don't get what they're so lazy I
don't
I'll tell you I forget what they just
come to work and they don't do yeah I
swear like they just talk bad [ __ ] yeah
and I'm like because they come here and
they they do yeah everything yeah they
do a lot they're they're the number one
um ethnic group like getting into Ivy
Leagues and [ __ ] they're like they're
crushing over Asians and everybody yeah
yeah
alms doing your back job
but the way I look at it the way that
Africans go hard on like black people is
like like it's like a like anything with
like traditional cultures like you know
like that's how I look at it it's like
oh oh yeah that's true I think about it
like you know in Asian cultures like
school and like that shit's important to
you guys and you know certain things
where it's like these are the the things
you have to do you have to you know what
what else is important you
you guys
numbers I mean oh [ __ ] Orange
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude growing up my mom would always tell
me she's like you guys have you guys
have it so good in American school if
you guys went to school in Singapore you
guys were all flunked out you guys could
never that's true though
wait really Singapore is Hardcore
schools in Asia is just teachers hit in
[ __ ] Asia too they'll beat your ass
yeah they're giving [ __ ] weapons it's
like in America like they're trying to
help you succeed and in Asia they're
trying to like suss you out that you
suck no really like they're trying to
find the garbage what makes this school
more difficult over there I don't know
well first of all it's from like seven
to five
like yeah it's like it's it's that's
already [ __ ] up and the next thing is
the teachers [ __ ] hit you and [ __ ]
damn yeah it's tough man I mean I was I
mean I mean that actually that's not a
bad deal really you get beaten to being
smart
that's tight I have to go everywhere
right I love the moment he's like wait a
minute
yeah
your benefit yeah it's like an assembly
line where you just gotta check the
quality of things and if something sucks
you just do this yeah but then like here
it's like no it's okay if you're dented
it's fine there's a place for you over
here it's a thrift shop in a vintage
shop so is there literally something
specific with with Asian cultures where
it's like you're gonna get this kind of
job or anything like that is there a
thing like that I think it depends on
the country yeah it depends on the
country
but I think that there is something that
ties
all the Asians together when it comes to
the way they do school the way they do
teaching so everyone is kind of similar
across the board it's pretty well some
is more strict than others the shame is
universal the Shameless Universe yeah
the shame is like built in but here
there's not it's not that shameful like
I would say the tropical Asians in the
jungle Asians they like to party more
they have a lot more fun it's a balance
like yeah they were the tropical in
general all the ones by the equator the
Vietnamese people but they still go hard
at school and like whatever but they
also have a balance I think like they
know how to have a good time where the
the cold climate Asians the North Korea
Japanese all that [ __ ] like it's
literally just [ __ ] work till you die
That's The Stereotype That's The
Stereotype That's The Stereotype yeah
yeah they just they just do everything
precisely on time some in that situation
in the Asian culture get the [ __ ] out of
here
it's a stereotype but it's also a
statistic though like the suicide rate
in Japan and Korea are [ __ ] high yeah
yeah so if they miss a test yeah the
pressure it's the structure of how their
schooling works so like let's say um so
for example let's say there's only like
five universities that are the top
schools right and then so like you're
you're talking about a country that has
like 100 million people so then like
these tests that you take in high school
determine if you could get into those
top schools or not if you could get into
those top schools then you could work
for the biggest companies like Sony
Toyota whatever and then but if you
can't though then you're probably not
gonna so that test determines and where
you're gonna be in life and they're all
about class
uh to break out of your middle class the
middle class is huge but the middle
class to break out of that break out of
it it didn't they're also a lot about
like Saving Face though and like pride
in that way so it's not always just like
you need to like get this position or
you need to like go to this school
um for your success that's obviously the
The Superficial element but there's also
like you need to do this or you'll bring
Dishonored to our family you need to be
able to do this otherwise yeah there's a
lot of pressure yeah that [ __ ] sucks
okay you get a lot of benefits
you like Asian chicks though
your eyes are really small that's pretty
convenient
your eyes are pretty small yeah smaller
than I feel like when I look at them I
feel like they live life 95 work and
obligations and five percent fun that's
how I see there and I feel like
Americans they they they work like night
like five percent of the time and 95
percent of the time they're having fun
yeah that's what it looks like to me
wait were you guys as parents harming
you guys my parents are pretty hard yeah
pretty hard not by Asian standards yeah
but it's that's what I'm saying but I
guess my age American Standards but it's
my parents were losing that's true yeah
earlier though about like Africans and
African-Americans same thing like the
Asian American experience and the Asian
experience are also very very different
we're lazy too yeah okay okay yeah yeah
very different yeah oh yeah I think
we're all bums dude yeah isn't that
crazy my cousin's schedule is starting
in like Middle School was seven till
five and then you have like a quick 30
minute on your bike you [ __ ] grab a
snack and then you have to go to tutor
or Academy because the testing is so
important like the test Joe was talking
about it's not just that what gets you
into college it's what's going to
determine your quality of life for the
rest of your life so it's almost like
testing into a cast system so you can't
like in in America you have so many like
lateral moves you can do you know I used
to be a chef but now I do this or I do
whatever over there you count you they
don't have that kind of Mobility so it's
like if you become a doctor you're
[ __ ] set if you don't then you're
[ __ ] that's how they view it squid
games imagine yeah yeah imagine if your
essay imagine if your SAT scores
determine your future yeah that's what
it's like so my cousin would
[ __ ] right go to school at 5
2 Academy from six to nine and then
after he has to do homework for the
school and for the Academy
a lot of homework and you better fall in
love with the right family too you know
I mean if you're gonna get married to
somebody or something like that like it
better be with the right family with the
right upbringing or the right class you
always got to climb up the ladder right
like that's why I think the birth rate
in Japan and Korea is so bad like
they're not popping out enough kids and
people aren't getting married and [ __ ]
yeah
what's happening
yeah yeah
yeah they spill them they put in man
hey what's that place in Japan where
they live people gonna do suicide oh
that horse yeah it's not where they left
oh yeah
we got three trees over here
wow also suicide's not like a sin you
know that's very Christian oh that's
true oh yeah yeah so like if you kill
yourself you're a thou shall not kill
you there's some water in that too yeah
that's well because it's in the Asian
culture well Japanese Japanese because
other Asians don't suicide all day maybe
Korean
it's not up it's not a Pastime sport so
like so it's like um you know like have
you heard of the Samurais cutting their
own guts yes yes yeah so that's like an
honor thing they don't do that anymore
but killing yourself giving the honor to
do that killing yourself is like oh um
I'm a burden so let me get out of here
and I'm not gonna deal with this [ __ ] so
like
um the mentality is different so like
let's say uh so back then right let's
say like your your village is getting
raided and then so um the women what
they'll do is they'll be like [ __ ] we're
gonna get taken for hostage so I'm just
gonna kill my kids and kill myself
before those guys can rape me and then
use me as a hostage
with the with the guys yeah or let's say
a soldier kind of failed his [ __ ] or he
he he and then everyone's just talking
about like what a little [ __ ] he is and
he goes oh yeah and he'll spill his guts
and be like check this out [ __ ]
oh you know I'm sorry and then they're
like whoa they're he's too hardcore oh
you think I'm a little [ __ ] they're
like damn he really so they're like he
ain't no [ __ ] well they did that in the
long in the ancient times it's like they
don't do that anymore right but then but
then just you know what you know what I
love I love how much you guys know about
your culture wait wait I love that this
is another classic [ __ ] Joe video
where we go from South African Vibes of
feudal Japan I was just thinking that
I'm like how do we end up with people in
Japan
I love it I love it there's like a
gravity
basically I'm trying to explain the the
the evolution
then fast forward to 100 more years
later right like if people off
themselves it's not really like the same
way that Americans it's still sad but
it's not the same way that they look at
it over there it's it's still [ __ ] up
and it's like why but then at the same
time like you get it
yeah all I'm saying is a fever I got
jungle fever Honeys was [ __ ] thick
and amazing it was amazing you with a
black girl am I with one yeah no
currently no no oh I said currently as
if I had offices
no definitely not no um but um they are
you ever been to a club like out here
right and you know really yeah I've
never been to a clubhouse in L.A how
about Europe
no okay point is you know you know when
you go to the club and then like you
walk in there's like smug [ __ ] over
here sitting at this table or some
people are like on drugs or like some
people don't know what they're doing and
[ __ ] it's awkward and people just
standing around trying to [ __ ]
measure all right okay L.A clubs suck I
went to one [ __ ] club out there and
everybody just had the vibe everybody
just had oh like I was dancing the whole
time and we weren't freestyle you were
just vibing with people you were like
either sharing steps or like everybody
just caught a mood or you would dance by
somebody you dance in the bathroom you
know what I'm saying and things
everybody had some sort of Swag you know
what I'm saying probably because you're
at a dance convention
everyone's guessing this [ __ ] why you
gotta be a hater with those eyebrows
that's like me going to [ __ ] like the
Arnold Classic dude everyone was just
bus
y
like he came over and said wait what
[ __ ] bam your dog the way he looked
at you was like yeah
yeah you're shooting down African Vibes
I can't imagine the place where
everyone's just [ __ ] perfectly just
[ __ ] in Sinking oh I don't know you
but we doing this together
like that's what he was talking about
why they call it bouncing yeah why would
he understand all right why wouldn't he
you know what I mean one of us have you
ever been to anywhere else in Africa or
just South Africa was your first
experience that was my first time
because I heard it's just like America
but in Africa what does that mean you
mean South Africa specifically yeah wow
no it's like it's it's a it's Western
like it's super Western
yeah yes you know what I mean like it
has a similar history to us yeah you
know what's sick though I will say the
currency exchange right and especially
being at a casino oh my god did you play
casino you always play craps for hours
you know why why because like what's the
minimum on a craft stable in Vegas
like five at least that's but that's
like off strip oh yeah yeah like 20. 25
bucks like if you go like Bellagio you
go to win it's like 25 if you go to a
cheap place on strip maybe 10 yeah bro
they had it was they go buy a currency
Rand right and I I asked I was like
what's the minimum they're like 50 red
then I did the calculation I was like
that's two dollars and seventy cents wow
so I was playing for hours and I was up
and I was a big a big means I took on 15
bucks let's go
a lot of game huh yo you but the food is
actually you can buy a [ __ ] filet
steak for [ __ ] thirteen dollars I'll
drink 18 because it cost me 14 bucks let
me ask you did you try the grilled
chicken there like uh my friend was
telling me that they have this chicken
in Africa they have they the way that
they do chicken they said that the way
that they do too it's like
hey what do you mean
like grilled chicken just right off the
street like and then they have it's like
Perry pay or something it's like really
[ __ ] bomb and they don't have that
here in the states the Peri-Peri sauce
is definitely [ __ ] Bond there I will
say that but I need to see no [ __ ]
chickens walking around on the street uh
and then being done like like that yeah
wait so they just they have chicken on
the street yeah and then so my friend
was saying like like that's a really
popular thing to do it's like their
version of like just barbecue chicken
but then depending on where you're on in
Africa they have different seasonings
and he goes that's all he ate it's just
like every single time he finds like a
like a grilled chicken this place was so
westernized that there was no African
food there the only time I had African
food the entire time is when I went to a
lounge on the airport on my way home and
I have the body that makes sense and
baboti was bombed what's up
uh minced beef or whatever with like an
egg layer on top with like African
spices and you eat it with rice and it's
like [ __ ] delicious delicious that
was the only time I made African food
because Africans [ __ ] with rice yeah
yeah it was butter you know what one of
us you know
is
it
[Music]